>> Sean: PART TWO WITH MY
INTERVIEW TOMORROW.
SHE TRAVELED TO TO BASIS.
SHE WANTED TO THINK THE TROOPS.
THEY WILL BE SEPARATED, MANY OF
THEM, THIS HOLIDAY SEASON,
SEPARATED FROM THEIR LOVED ONES.
HERE IS SOME INCREDIBLE
BEHIND-THE-SCENES FOOTAGE.
>> MANY OF YOU HAVE RECENTLY
RETURNED HOME FROM DEPLOYMENT.
I AM HONORED TO BE ABLE TO SAY
WELCOME HOME AND THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING THE CALL OF DUTY.
WE KNOW THAT WE ARE FREE BECAUSE
YOU ARE BRAVE.
I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MY HUSBAND
WHEN I TELL YOU WE ARE FOREVER
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THE PRESIDENT AND I THINK YOU
FOR ALL THAT YOU DO.
AFTER WE LEAVE HERE, WILL BE
FLYING TO THE
USS GEORGE H.W. BUSH AIRCRAFT
CARRIER TO MEET WITH THE CREW ON
BOARD.
THAT STOP ALL NOT ONLY ALLOW ME
TO VISIT WITH MORE MEMBERS OF
OUR MILITARY BUT IT WILL BE VERY
MEANINGFUL AFTER THE RECENT
PASSING OF PRESIDENT BUSH.
I WANT TO LET YOU ALL KNOW THAT
THE PRESIDENT AND I ARE SO
GRATEFUL AND HAVE UNCONDITIONAL
APPRECIATION FOR ALL THAT YOU D
DO.
HELLO, EVERYONE.
I AM VERY HONORED TO BE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND YOUR SACRIFICE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR KEEPING US ALL
SAFE AND FREE.
THE PRESIDENT AND I ARE VERY
PROUD OF YOU, AND WE WISH YOU A
MERRY CHRISTMAS AND A HAPPY AND
HEALTHY NEW YEAR.